yeah man what are these drugs no freedom
[ __ ] is that those founding ways what it
is is honestly oh yeah Brendon and Brian
are dumb right right so so they're
technically dumb right so so what'd they
do with that entail if you're dumb
so what this is so what they do is a guy
yes
some guy just anyone let's say will be
like hey there's a new thing right let's
say ingest it right and it's good for
your health and so they go nah never
mind man who cares now let's see no
exactly
let's do a little improv I'll be the guy
you be you okay I'll be be okay so this
is what so normally okay who are you sir
sorry I'm just some guy there's a new
thing and it's out then you should
ingest it oh no thanks go [ __ ] yourself
okay all right yeah right that's how it
goes when right now now I'll do Brian
okay Brendan hey man what's up yeah yeah
I'm good man how are you and they just
are you I know yeah no I'm god I am some
guy because I don't think I've ever seen
you before
no you wouldn't have dumped some guy
there's a new thing you should get it
and you should ingest it give me all of
it okay
can you talk about it on your part a
hundred producers and I hope it makes
you do well yeah and makes you money
yeah and I will be your test subject
okay that's a gross now four months
later I have psoriasis what gave you so
[ __ ] lovely when he says when the guy
says hey have that and wash it down with
that get psoriasis yeah
oversimplification is it
we're so glad that we're getting banged
like what's that means feel oh yeah just
do your father steel know who Theo is
I've never met Leon feel 1va ugh that's
how you separate the ovine you bastard
Aviv on wheels God Theo mattes right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh
good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]